[Applause]
all right
yes everybody
yeah yeah yeah it's Friday right yeah
let's let loose
all right all right calm down calm down
you know it's Friday so that means we do
this first let's welcome tonight's guest
his eyes sparkle when he rips into
Meghan Markle Fox News contributor
Douglas Murray
like a kitchen knife she's sharp useful
and banned from airplanes Fox News
anchor Julie Banderas
his act is just like his hair pretty
thin comedian Joe DeVito
and she's like a major league baseball
game she goes on and on and costs guys a
fortune in beer Fox News contributor
captive
all right now before we get to some news
stories it's Friday so let's do this
Greg's leftovers
that's right it's leftovers this is
where I read the jokes that we didn't
use this week and as always it is my
first time reading these so if they suck
you get to kill a writer
here we go on Monday Superstar QB that's
uh short for quarterback cat Aaron
Rodgers was traded by the Green Bay
Packers to the New York Jets Roger says
he looks forward to spending more time
with his family during the playoffs
[Laughter]
Sports joke
legendary TV host Jerry Springer passed
away on Thursday a small service will be
held for family close friends strippers
dwarves skinheads and baby mamas
in an interview Steven Spielberg says he
regrets editing E.T to remove guns from
policemen's hands in his defense
Spielberg said E.T was way ahead on
transgender issues
[Laughter]
crew
according to astrobiologists space
tourists will need to sign legal waivers
Banning them from having sex while in
space
disappointing Travelers who assume the
voyage would include a little Tang
[Laughter]
[Applause]
on Monday on Monday CNN parted ways with
Dawn lemon who complained
that was the big news
who complained they didn't reach out to
him before he was terminated adding if
they wanted to keep the news quiet they
could have aired it during his show
a new analysis of census data shows that
gen Z women are identifying as bisexual
in record numbers making for complicated
first dates since no one knows how to
pay for dinner
[Laughter]
Kentucky Congressman James Comer has
accused the Biden family of running and
influence peddling scheme which is news
to anyone who's seen Joe Biden's
peddling
[Laughter]
that's cute
I screwed it up
all right I'll take it
speculation is rampant that Hunter Biden
is living at the White House sources
were tipped off after a janitor was
overheard saying I haven't cleaned up
this much evidence so since Bill Clinton
left
[Applause]
I thought it was going to be more
disgusting I was hoping for it during a
Florida campaign stop former president
Trump handed out pizza and asked does
anybody want a piece that I've eaten
[Laughter]
It's The surest Sign yet that he wants
Chris Christie for VP
[Laughter]
Energy Secretary Jennifer granholm said
this week she wants all U.S military
vehicles to be electric by 2030.
the hardest part will be finding
extension cords for the tanks
that's not how they work
new details have emerged about last
week's explosion of these SpaceX rocket
apparently Engineers tried to prevent it
from prematurely exploding by telling it
to think about baseball
oh
yeah yeah the U.S embassy in Sudan has
been evacuated making it the fourth
Embassy around the world to have been
evacuated under President Biden wow this
guy's good said one expert
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and finally those are my two favorite
words President Biden had words of
encouragement for Americans still
trapped in Sudan saying how hard is it
to get out of a four-door car
laughs
that was good that was a good one that
was worth a chuckle
all right now to the news let me put up
my news glasses
the time says we shouldn't care if Joe
Biden's not all there here's an easy
medical test if you don't know by now
that Joe Biden's brain is mush then you
may also have dementia time to start
injecting balance of nature
anyone who does see the deterioration of
President Poopypants
you won't be surprised to discover that
the New York Times has no problem with
this decline in fact who needs a healthy
president they argue well what's next
Blind Pilots quote strange as it may
sound the American government can
function without a healthy president
well that's good to know you jackasses
these are the same dopes mind you who
wanted Trump thrown out of office with
the 25th Amendment or with the phony
Russia gay narrative when he was deemed
unfit that was an existential threat but
Joe being a cognitive disaster well
that's just adorable
it's like having a puppy with three legs
you can use the other three and he hops
like a bunny
and it's so cute when he gets lost
but you think at least one time he'd get
up and say I'm running for president
where where am I going you think at
least one time he'd get up and say I'm
running for president uh where where am
I going where the hell Rebecca
I want to get out though no over there
[Applause]
you know
I don't think we deserved him he's just
too good for us the times writer also
compared Biden to FDR and Reagan who had
their own health problems and pointed a
cabinet secretaries and military leaders
who got us through it yeah but those
guys never got lost in their own yard by
the way did you know that the one thing
Biden thought when he got to be
president was that he'd get to give
orders but he takes more orders than he
did
by the way the one thing I thought when
I got to be president
I get to give orders
but I take more orders than I ever did
yeah
yeah and those orders include don't
touch anything on your desk and and
please stop sniffing our children
it is kind of cute though him thinking
he could be president you know just
because an airline pilot pins Wings on a
five-year-old doesn't really mean he
gets to fly the jumbo jet
[Laughter]
I wonder if it's hard for Joe to keep
track of the last place he was
trying to think what was the last where
was the last place I was it's hard to
keep track
um
I was I mean yeah you're right Ireland
maybe that was Dr Jill pretending to be
a child
Ireland
and there you go children can out think
him and need fewer diapers
what say you Joe
no no no look look the kid didn't let me
finish
or I take orders sometimes sometimes I
take uh you know like a food order for
the staff I'll say yeah
nobody wants coffee
um what does it say everybody anybody
cool buddy I just made up a word
do you ever make up a word I do that
sometimes
like sniffelicious
you know what snivelitious means
you want to know you gotta get in close
all right
that was amazing gotta get this straight
Douglas in America if a Republican
president is deemed unfit it's an
existential threat but if it's Democrat
it's like you really don't need a
healthy president after all isn't that
amazing yeah it's like it's fine this
machine runs itself yes this isn't the
car this is the United States of America
yeah uh the idea I mean if if the time
that she thinks this is the case and
they should have told us ahead of the
last election as well is that right it
doesn't really matter who's President
and we don't really care because in the
end it's run by someone else the by the
way the island thing that was gruesome
yes that was really also considering
this president has avoided more press
conferences than any previous president
the fact that when he does appear in
public it's in front of a small group of
children and he can't do questions and
answers with them either we're never a
problem wouldn't that be great if that
was actually like Peter ducey's child so
you had like
then you got Peter Ducey and then you
got another Ducey
Julie Julie had a question for you he
finally Joe finally admitted what we
we've been totally saying that Joe
wasn't running the show that he takes
orders that it's really a bunch of
wokesters that are pulling all the
strings he just said it I almost admire
the fact that he admitted it I do I
think every man actually should follow
in his footsteps and admit that they do
not give the orders yes but women agree
in here they're laughing inside but um
but I will say this you know when you
compare this president to past
presidents okay so the the times
compared him to Roosevelt who had
numerous health issues Reagan who had
Alzheimer's after he left the office
that's the whole point there's the
difference right he's currently in
office so to say that a president's
Health Fitness and mental Fitness is not
important in order to hold the office
the highest office in the land is
absolutely bogus so what do you make of
this uh Joey well I think for
presidential Health they've lowered the
bar it's lower than the one that keeps
them from falling out of bed at night oh
no what is the spin they're trying to
say many chickens who've had their heads
cut off lead rewarding lives for much
it's so it's so ridiculous that they're
actually trying to say if it doesn't
matter if he's in charge by comparing
him to FDR oh I mean the the president
with polio who died in office that's
that's the standard we're setting for
performance and I think you can tell
because whoever yelled at Ireland I
don't know if it was a child or maybe a
leprechaun yes not sure what that voice
but I think the keyframe with the press
conference is is to keep having younger
and younger people ask questions until
finally he's just yelling at a sonogram
yeah
kind of hit on something you know FDR
died in office and statistically I mean
Biden
the what the Democrats are putting forth
a candidate that statistically
statistically will die in office he's
already passed the life expectancy that
I'll have yes
I uh I just think it's very revealing
that they are setting the bar at
functioning yes because
I can admit that there have been times
in my life when I've given myself credit
for still functioning right
but that's not when things were going
well no
but I'm like you did it cat you got out
of bed that's not this that's not
bragging yeah that means that things are
going I mean vote for me I'm out of bed
sometimes like that's all that they
couldn't have said things are going
worse better than setting the bar at
functioning yeah you know what it is
it's they act like he has a hangover
yeah oh you know he does a pretty good
job today yes get through the day you're
the president bro oh man I could go for
a cheeseburger to shake
so yeah I saw Yeah well yeah that's what
I had to offer oh wow all right let's
get to number one book what just mailing
it in
mailing it I think the word you're
looking for is succinct there you go all
right before we go you can now pre-order
my book my new book cat the king of late
nights oh this book's great there's even
autographed editions available look at
that cover is that beautiful is that
really the cover that is really the
cover yeah it's not time to redesign
they had to uh they had to actually dial
back the muscles
now you get that book plus tickets for
my upcoming tour at gutfeld.com are you
are you performing in Chicago to this
weekend yeah on Sunday are you still do
are there still tickets yeah they're
still tickets where is it it's at Park
West in Chicago and Sunday at 8pm it's
gonna be so much fun where do people get
those tickets you can oh I have a
website therealcottemf.com hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else